bonjour bonjour à toutes et à tous
heureux de vous retrouver pour une
nouvelle semaine de sens public votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débat et le
reportage sur Public Sénat 90 minutes
deux grands thèmes pour donner du sens à
l'actualité grâce à nos experts à
quelques heures d'intervalle Marine Le
Pen et Éric Zemmour ont fait leur
rentrée hier stratégie de communication
similaire mais destin politique
dissemblables leader de reconquête se
remet difficilement de son échec à la
présidentielle quand Marine Le Pen
réussit sa normalisation comment
prépare-t-il les prochaines échéances
sénatoriales puis européenne ce sera le
thème de notre premier débat et puis
dans 45 minutes trois jours après le
tremblement de terre qui a ravagé le
Maroc on va tirer les premières leçons
de cette catastrophe notamment politique
le royaume chérifien n'accepte l'aide
que de quatre pays pour l'instant et la
France n'en fait pas partie
c'est vraiment une mauvaise querelle une
querelle tout à fait déplacée le Maroc
est souverain il est seul en mesure de
tes renseigner quelles sont ses besoins
et le rythme auquel et souhaite que des
réponses soient apportées à son besoin
nous avons fait une offre une
soixantaine de pays on fait des offres
et le Maroc décide souverainement
d'appeler tel ou tel de ses propositions
la diplomatie du séisme est à l'oeuvre
on l'analyse avec nos invités tout à
l'heure mais d'abord donc l'extrême
droite qui faisait sa rentrée ce
dimanche avec une Marine Le Pen toujours
bien installée dans son rôle de premier
opposante à Emmanuel Macron Flora
sauvage
séduction hier en terrain conquis pour
Marine Le Pen la chef de fil des députés
du rassemblement national a fait sa
rentrée politique à Hénin-Beaumont dans
le Pas-de-Calais avec en ligne de mire
les élections européennes prévues le 9
juin prochain en 2019 son parti était
arrivé en tête cette fois Marine Le Pen
fait la promotion de la liste conduite
par Jordan Bardella c'est la seule
élection nationale avant les
présidentielles dans son discours Marine
Le Pen cible Emmanuel Macron pour
s'imposer comme la prétendante naturelle
à la présidentielle de 2027 et les
désormais loin le un moment où
l'opposition que nous incarnions n'était
qu'une force de contestation plus que
jamais nous incarnons un espoir pas un
mot en revanche de la liste concurrente
de reconquête menées par sa nièce Mario
maréchal sous le soleil de plomb de
Gréoux-les-Bains dans les Alpes de
Haute-Provence l'ex-candidat la
présidentielle Éric Zemmour a intronisé
sa tête de liste aux élections
européennes qui exhortent les électeurs
de droite aller rejoindre te lance un
appel à tous les électeurs LR à tous les
électeurs de droite à ceux qui comme
François-Xavier Bel-Ami devrait être à
nos côtés rejoignez-nous dans les rangs
du RN on déplore la liste déposée par
reconquête si la France est en danger de
mort comme le dit Marion maréchal et
Éric Zemmour alors à ce moment on se
présente pas dans son coin pour faire 5
ou 6% à une élection et pour participer
d'une forme de division des voix au
moment même encore une fois où nous
devrions les unir pour envoyer un
message très clair face à Emmanuel
Macron dans cette élections
nourrit l'espoir de siphonner l'élector
at du parti LR pour dépasser les 5% des
voix et faire son entrée au Parlement
européen Jordan Bardella peut se
rassurer à neuf mois les élections
européennes sa liste arrive largement en
tête des intentions de vote
la discrétion payante de Marine Le Pen
c'est le thème de notre débat avec
Jean-Yves Camus bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes directeur de l'Observatoire des
radicalités politiques à la Fondation
Jean Jaurès Nonna Mayer bonsoir
bienvenue à vous aussi vous êtes
chercheuse au CNRS rattachée au Centre
d'études européens de Sciences Po auteur
de cet article un vent de renouveau la
recomposition des John bergames
selectoral élection présidentielle
française de 2022 ça nous intéresse
parce que c'était vraiment c'était
publié La Revue française de sciences
politiques question de genre de sexisme
et de comparaison entre le vote Le Pen
Zemmour notamment Adrien broche bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes responsable des
études politiques et publiées de
l'Institut via Voice et vous avez publié
dans Libération il y a quelques jours
une étude passionnante justement sur
autour du vote Marine Le Pen et de sa
normalisation Mathieu croissanto bonsoir
et bienvenue politique je vais commencer
j'arrive Camus par le choix des mots
pour caractériser Marine Le Pen on se
pose souvent la question et on voudrait
vous la poser souvent est-ce que vous
parlez toujours d'extrême droite
vous n'avez pas échappé que je dirigeais
centre de recherche qui s'intitule
observatoire des radicalité politique
des radicalités
j'ai plutôt tendance à utiliser droit
tradicale
le terme extrême droite a été largement
justifié dans les années 70 bien sûr
80-90 il était approprié à l'époque où
Jean-Marie Le Pen une dirigeait le Front
national
je pense que Marine Le Pen a changé le
style et la garder bien évidemment les
fondamentaux mais finalement quand on
regarde la dose de radicalité des uns et
des autres c'est aujourd'hui clairement
reconquête qui est
plus radical faut-il dire plus extrême
je ne sais pas que le RN et puis un
petit peu partout en Europe c'est le
même courant que l'on voit c'est-à-dire
une extrême droite traditionnelle qui
est en marge qui dans beaucoup de pays
est devenu folklorique et qui finalement
évoluent pour prendre la place et ça
c'est fondamentalement intéressant et
fondamentalement dangereux pour la
démocratie deux droites conservatrices
libérales qui ont bien du mal à
renouveler leur logiciel idéologique et
bien du mal à garder leurs électeurs
alors justement ces électeurs de la
manière est-ce que est-ce que on va
rester sur Marine Le Pen pour l'instant
mais est-ce qu'il se sentent d'extrême
droite et s'ils se disent d'extrême
droite de moins en moins il n'aime pas
le terme simplement quand on leur
demande tout bêtement de se classer sur
la bonne vieille échelle gauche droite
et rien marqué il y a juste marqué
gauche droite et des godets bien il y a
soit une place nulle part ou en dehors
pouvez se mettre tout au bout à droite
et quand on demande dans tous les
sondages aux personnes sont des où
est-ce qu'elles placent les partis
politiques et bien quand même le parti
de Marine Le Pen et juste avant le parti
d'Éric Zemmour tout au bout à droite et
le terme en anglais fort right serait
pas mal c'est tout au bout donc pas
extrême parce que ça nous c'est connoté
les ligues les années 30 donc non mais
droite extrême en tout cas tout au bout
à droite ils le sont tous les deux à
droite Adrien Bosch bon je commence par
là c'est pas la première fois que je
pose cette question pardon de l'avoir
utilisé en ouverture de débat mais ça
m'offre la transition avec cette alors
vous employez terme banalisation on peut
parler de normalisation aussi de de
l'image de Marine Le Pen vous l'avez
donc étudié pour ce sondage allié dans
Libération avec des opinions négatives
qui restent majoritaires c'est
51%, mais elles sont en chutes fortes
moins 13 points en deux ans les opinions
positives à l'inverse grain de 10 points
quelle leçon principale on rentrera un
petit peu dans le détail tout à l'heure
mais quelle leçon principale vous tirez
de cette étude je pense que c'est une
étude qui fait la synthèse en fait
effectivement de d'un certain nombre de
commentaires qu'on a pu mener d'enquête
qui ont été menées aussi notamment par
Jean-Yves Camus et nona meilleur sur ces
dernières années depuis maintenant un
certain nombre de temps c'est à dire que
la politique de respectabilité en tout
cas cette première étape là elle a
globalement été payante pour Marine Le
Pen à partir du moment où 51% des
Français c'est à dire une majorité plus
d'un sur deux considère qu'elle est
probablement la prochaine présidente de
la République c'est-à-dire que voilà il
y a un certain nombre de digues ne
serait-ce que dans l'imaginaire qui ont
qui ont sauté je pense que ça c'est le
premier point le deuxième c'est qu'on a
essayé de travailler aussi sur les
crédibilités les compétences là aussi
Marine Le Pen en deux ans puisqu'on a
essayé de comparer par rapport à une
précédente enquête qu'on avait menée en
novembre 2021 là aussi elle monte à la
fois sur son périmètre d'intervention
traditionnel les enjeux régaliens ordre
police immigration délinquance mais
aussi sur les questions sociales ce qui
accompagne aussi la mue depuis longtemps
observer du du Front national du
rassemblement national pardon sur sur
ces enjeux là et le progresse sur la
protection sociale et le progresse même
sur la lutte contre les inégalités entre
les femmes et les hommes et le progresse
sur la jeunesse etc donc aussi un seuil
de crédibilité qui a été atteint par
Marine Le Pen Marine Le Pen je le disais
en titre à l'aise dans ce costume de
première opposante à Emmanuel Macron ce
dimanche c'était son discours de rentrée
à Hénin-Beaumont et à l'ironisait sur
l'impuissance du gouvernement face à
l'inflation en réalité si on n'avait pas
de gouvernement ce serait à peu près la
même chose
c'est que vous modériez vos prix si vous
pouviez avoir l'amabilité et la
gentillesse de bien vouloir ne pas
procéder à des augmentations à deux
chiffres du prix de l'alimentation nous
en serions heureux et ça ça n'est pas un
gouvernement un gouvernement ça gouverne
ça prend des décisions
ça ne se contente pas de pleurnicher
auprès de tel ou tel secteur économique
pour obtenir
hypothétiquement quelque chose
évidemment c'est toujours plus facile à
dire quand on est dans l'opposition
j'arrive Camus ce thème du pouvoir
d'achat c'est sa porte Marine Le Pen
très clairement depuis depuis on va dire
deux ans ou en tout cas
18 mois
c'est quoi ça vous a pas étonné parce
qu'elle a un sens politique elle a elle
a trois campagnes électorales derrière
elle elle a ça fait longtemps qu'elle
mortelle le thème du pouvoir d'achat
beaucoup plus longtemps que ça il y
avait eu une première tentative en 1995
qu'on avait qualifié un petit peu
rapidement de Tournon social du Front
national c'était à l'occasion des
grandes grèves de l'automne 95 mais ça
ne marche pas ça ne marche pas parce que
fondamentalement Jean-Marie Le Pen et
ceux qui l'entouraient était des
ryano-tachéiens libéraux
donc le thème était resté le terme était
resté tournant social mais ça
recueillait pas énormément d'as
sentiments et puis je suis Marine Le Pen
je sens une différence avec son père qui
est une réelle en bâtie avec les petites
gens
je crois qu'elle est à l'aise dans ces
électorat d'Hénin-Beaumont qui l'a élu
et c'est pas pour rien non plus qu'elle
a choisi cet endroit pour sa rentrée
politique elle aurait pu en choisir
d'autres parmi les villes notamment qui
sont gouvernées par le rassemblement
national elle est là c'est-à-dire là
mais il y a bien d'autres régions en
France où ce sera
similaire ou les questions de pouvoir
d'achat d'inflation d'inégalités qui se
creusent de perspective réduite de
l'ascenseur social vont être cruciales
et ils vont être certainement au moins
aussi crucial que les questions d'ordre
public sur lesquelles de toute façon
Marine Le Pen comme sur le thème de
l'immigration aura toujours si je veux
dire sera toujours des positifs de la
marque mais est-ce qu'elle a toujours
besoin de parler d'immigration ou du
régalien à ces électeurs Marine Le Pen
ou est-ce que finalement c'est pas
tellement intégré que que c'est plus
nécessaire mais ils le savent et quand
on les interroge les acteurs on voit que
ce qui est le premier facteur explicatif
de ce vote c'est cette ce sentiment
d'insécurité éc culturelle à l'égard de
l'immigration et à l'égard de l'islam
donc effectivement elle n'a plus besoin
de le dire mais quand même son programme
sa colonne vertébrale c'est la
préférence nationale rebaptisée priorité
nationale donc c'est quand même quelque
chose qui avoir avec l'immigration avec
les dés qui a les Français les Français
d'abord et puis les autres mais c'est
vrai qu'elle n'a même plus besoin de le
dire ça parle pour elle par ailleurs
elle a l'intelligence de d'utiliser
pour tous les thèmes de son programme il
y a cet axe ethnocentriste entré sur soi
c'est-à-dire même quand elle va
s'adresser aux femmes elle va leur dire
que moi je me bats pour votre sécurité
mais qui sont les fauteurs d'insécurité
c'est les étrangers violeurs potentiels
je dis à tout est passé à travers le
filtre le prisme de la crainte de
l'Immigration et de l'islam
je suis frappé parce qu'il y a un
travail d'image on en a parlé et puis un
travail quand même un travail de fond
sur le travail d'images qui est quelque
chose qui m'a frappé dans votre sondage
c'est la dangerosité c'est-à-dire cette
étiquette de partie dangereux qui
collait aux Front national autrefois et
au rassemblement national jusqu'ia peu
aujourd'hui ne colle plus puisque
l'étiquette abaissée et elle s'est
lissée donc elle a perdu son statut
d'épouvantail de la classe politique
quand d'autres l'ont récupéré ce statut
du pouvoir et que ce soit à l'extrême
droite et un Zemmour ou que ce soit dans
son style de bruit de fureur Jean-Luc
Mélenchon on le voit ça le sondage
qui est nettement en faveur du travail
d'image qui est qui à mon avis profond
et c'est n'est plus un épouvantail
dangereux pour les électeurs et l'autre
chose sur le fond et je vous rejoins
c'est qu'on voit bien qu'elle elle
développe sa grille sur tous les thèmes
et là il y a un thème elle a fait le
pouvoir d'achat après avoir fait la
sécurité de l'immigration qu'elle est en
train d'investir qui est qui est
l'écologie d'une certaine façon ou là
elle est sur un travail de défense des
petits contre les gros des campagnes
contre les bobos des villes de des
Français des territoires des terroirs
contre ces foudres européens qui
voudraient nous imposer des normes donc
on voit bien qu'il y a même une matrice
tactique mais pas seulement
sont en train d'imprégner en profondeur
tout le programme dans la vie de
rassemblance il y avait effectivement
plusieurs thèmes il y avait il y avait
la dangerosité et la compétence question
similaires diriez-vous que le
rassemblement national est plus ou moins
compétent que la France insoumise là
aussi 35 % plus compétents 18 % moins
compétents
est-ce qu'il y a une part de
responsabilité
comment je peux tourner ça là cette
stratégie du conflit permanent qui est
la stratégie de théoriser par Jean-Luc
mélenchute depuis très longtemps et
imposer ou en tout cas accepter par ses
partenaires de la nuque à l'Assemblée
nationale depuis depuis un an est-ce
qu'elle profite finalement à Marine Le
Pen aujourd'hui est-ce que votre sondage
démontre pas ça on le ressentait
en tout cas on prend une photographie
d'un résultat les causes elles sont
évidemment toujours pluriel maintenant
je pense qu'effectivement il est
difficile de ne pas imputer un
ersatz de responsabilité quand même
là-dessus au rapport de force entretenu
entre la France insoumise dans le des
opposition elle rassemblement national
d'abord parce que je suis assez en
désaccord parfois avec le discours
ambiant qui consiste à dire que de toute
manière le le climat médiatique
thématique profite au rassemblement
national on sort quand même de une année
et demi voire deux années où la question
sociale a été très structurante dans le
débat public je crois l'inflation la
crise énergétique la question des
retraites une partie de gauche aurait pu
en particulier j'aurais pu en profiter
je pense que là effectivement le leur
champ d'intervention traditionnelle a
été présents ils ont pas tellement su
s'en saisir le autre chose c'est que
effectivement je pense que la séquence
on a on a demandé Marine Le Pen
sort-elle renforcée des séquences
émeutes de la séquence retraite on a une
majorité de Français qui considère
qu'elle sort renforcée dans les deux cas
ou quasiment dans les deux cas
l'attitude la discrétion parfois la
discrétion proactive aussi de Marine Le
Pen et du rassemblement national bonance
débat à l'Assemblée elle est sûrement
aussi là dessus et là ça part de
responsabilité dans cette
crédibilisation quand Marine Le Pen doit
rappeler à l'ordre un député de
l'opposition LFI qui traite un ministre
d'assassin c'est quand même une image
qui est assez édifiante de là où on en
est arrivé une présidente de groupe de
d'extrême droite rappelle à l'ordre
républicain un député l'opposition c'est
quand même assez édifiant votre avis sur
cette je pose la même question dans ce
comparatif rassemblement national et les
filles d'abord ne comparatif qui va être
le plus intéressant en 2027 et même aux
élections européennes c'est pas celui
entre rassemblement national et les
filles c'est celui entre le
rassemblement national et les forces qui
se rangeront derrière le président de la
République ou celui qui leur a désigné
pour
qu'il aura adoubé pour lui succéder ça
faut pas l'oublier la seconde chose si
on regarde j'allais dire presque
philosophiquement le débat
la théorie du conflit permanent je
l'appelle plutôt théorie du conflit
nécessaire
dans les écrits de Chantal mouf dans ce
dernier sous Laclos comme d'ailleurs
dans les écrits de kalschmidt il n'est
pas dit que le conflit doit être
permanent
il est dit que le conflit est
structurant des sociétés et qu'il existe
naturellement des conflits qu'il faut
surmonter certes mais qui nécessite des
choix c'est-à-dire que on peut pas faire
plaisir à tout le monde et finalement
Marine Le Pen aussi elle est dans une
vision là
quand elle design Bruxelles quand elle
parle des élites quand elle parle son
père par les navires beaucoup des gros
etc dans une veine pouvait lisse elle
dit bien à un moment donné si vous
écoutez si vous réécoutez l'extrait que
nous venons de voir on peut pas faire
plaisir à la fois à ceux qui augmentent
leur marge dans la grande distribution
et on consommateur qui passe à la caisse
et le rôle du gouvernement à un moment
donné c'est de décider celui à qui
véritablement il veut donner l'avantage
la seule chose c'est que ces stratégies
du conflit nécessaire on peut l'assumer
diverses manières c'est à dire qu'on
peut poser les conflits nécessaires et
expliquer qu'il faut les transcender et
puis on peut faire du bruit
et puis on peut faire du bruit en
permanence en confondant effectivement
le bruit le conflit et là ça débouche
certainement pas sur un résultat positif
alors dans le jeu de Marine Le Pen il y
a un atout qui s'appelle Jordan Bardella
Mathieu vous avez choisi de nous en
parler ce soir oui parce que ce sera
vrai sur vraisemblablement pardon
l'homme de l'année du rassemblement
national c'est celui qui repose la
délicate mission de mener la liste RN
nos prochaines élections européennes et
la pression sur ces épaules n'est pas
mince puisque il s'agit de rééditer le
coup de maître de 2019 arriver en tête
devant les partitions d'Emmanuel Macron
au soir de l'élection alors nouvelle
victoire le conforterait dans sa
position de dauphin et un mauvais score
l'inverse évidemment contrarié un peu
ses ambitions Jordan Bardella il est
jeune il est très jeune il fêtera dans
deux jours c'est 28 ans mais c'est pas
franchement ce qu'on appelle non plus un
homme nouveau ça fait déjà une bonne
décennie qui milite et il est déjà monté
très haut puisqu'il est président du
parti depuis un an et lui avec 85% des
voix on le rappelle en novembre 22 c'est
le premier en fait à diriger le
mouvement sans porter le nom de Le Pen
ce que d'aucun guacama avantage pour ses
futurs ambitions mais qu'on ne s'y
trouve pas pour autant puisque Jordan
Bardella qui vit en couple avec la nièce
de la patronne et donc une petite fille
de Marine Le Pen fait bien partie du
clan alors c'est aujourd'hui devenu une
figure incontournable du rassemblement
national et même d'une certaine façon de
la scène politique française cet été il
a même bénéficié d'une forme
d'adougouement symbolique en recevant un
coup de fil du président Emmanuel Macron
comment expliquer vous cette ascension
fulgurante il y a quelque chose qui
tient à son talent parce que Jordan
Bardella n'en manque pas pour développer
un argumentaire pour appuyer là où ça
fait mal pour balancer une punchline
dans un style moderne et pro près qui
fait de lui un des batteur redoutable
selon tous ces tous ces adversaires mais
là encore qu'on s'y trompe pas parce que
ce style moderne en apparence Bardella
fait quand même ses premières armes dans
le sillage de figure bien connu de
l'extrême droite radical puisque on sait
qu'il a notamment démarré avec la figure
sulfureuse de Frédéric Châtillon qui fut
président du guide bien connu donc il y
a une part de talents il y a une part de
travail ensuite et ça pour le coup il
est sérieux voir besogneux mais il
prépare ses dossiers comme c'est
intervention ça rend d'une certaine
façon avec une forme d'amateurisme qu'on
pouvait trouver et qui longtemps prévu
au Front national un peu moins
rassemblement national mais voilà les
gens se présentaient pour faire des
coups d'éclat dans les émissions mais
pas forcément en travaillant sur le fond
et puis la dernière explication c'est sa
forme de loyauté enfin ça loyauté à
Marine Le Pen qui comme son père avait
jusqu'ici eu souvent et à partir avec
ses premiers lieutenants alors jusqu'à
présent Jordan Bardella a su imprimer sa
marque et parfois même cette différence
on l'a vu sur la Russie notamment cette
année sans pour autant aller trop loin
c'est toujours la faire de l'élastique
jusqu'où le tendre pour exister sans
voilà mais ça fait mentir en tout cas
l'adage impitoyable de Jean-Marie Le Pen
on s'en souvient selon lequel le destin
d'un dauphin c'est parfois de s'échouer
alors pour ces européennes quelques son
axe de campagne alors lui-même Jordan
Bardella il est issu d'une famille
d'origine italienne il a un
arrière-grand-père kabyle et il n'hésite
pas à faire de la lutte contre donc
évidemment le classique son cheval de
bataille et même s'il ne le dit pas trop
fort ou en tout cas pas toujours c'est
un identitaire convaincu un jardin de
Bardella il est convaincu que la preuve
civilisation civilisationnelle lui
permettra d'engranger des points sur un
terrain faut le dire où il y a quand
même pas mal de concurrence puisqu'on a
reconquête et puis on a des LR qui se
doivent lui son idée c'est de draguer
les électeurs déçus provocateurs on l'a
vu dans l'extrait qu'on a diffusé en
début d'émission il a même invité Marion
maréchal à le rejoindre ce week-end ce
qu'il ne fera évidemment pas elle qui
sera sa principale adversaire dans cette
élection merci Mathieu vous nous l'avez
dit faites la fêter ses 28 ans dans deux
jours donna Mayer les lectorat jeune
c'est l'un des piliers du rassemblement
national aujourd'hui alors ça dépendait
des élections aujourd'hui oui il y a eu
des moments par exemple en 2002 c'était
plutôt un électoragé ou sur les thèmes
de la sécurité mais là on fait avec nos
analyses un peu poussées ou on essaie de
voir toutes choses égales par ailleurs
en prenant en compte l'âge le sexe la
profession la religion l'âge est une
variable fondamentale avec le votre
diplôme mais c'est vraiment dans les
catégories aujourd'hui des 18 35 ans et
plus particulièrement 24 35 c'est là que
Marine Le Pen fait de très loin ses
meilleurs scores donc là il sera
meilleur catégorie d'âge
maintenant ça n'a pas toujours été le
cas ça dépend des années et donc si on
combine la variable âge la variable
diplôme
vous avez déjà un gros pourcentage
d'explications de ce vote et c'est
intéressant parce que c'est pas la même
chose pour osemo Gémeaux il n'y a pas un
vote on pensait en commençant à
travailler dessus que ça serait un vote
des plus âgés non c'est le genre qui
joue là
d'être un électorat masculin l'énorme
différence entre ces deux électorats
c'est que
Eric Zemmour a réussi à rebuter
l'électorat féminin à peu près dans les
mêmes proportions que Jean-Marie Le Pen
à l'époque où il tenait le parti avec
ses propos à la fois sexistes viriliste
masculiniste et donc il y a maintenant
un énorme écart entre les deux qu'est-ce
qui reste de défouloir ou de
protestation dans le vote RN ou dans le
vote Le Pen aujourd'hui
mais dans tous les votes dans tous les
votes il y a toujours une partie de
votre compte ça dépend de qui sont les
candidats donc il y a une partie de
protestation entier élite si vous voulez
cette dimension populiste elle se réduit
finalement à être contre être contre les
élites être contre ceux qui nous
gouvernent classe
aux idées du rassemblement depuis très
longtemps ceux qui sont là je dis on
voit clairement que quand on essaie de
faire un modèle explicatif vient en tête
même si c'est évident c'est une échelle
d'ethnocentrique c'est-à-dire rejet des
immigrés des étrangers et des musulmans
c'est ça qui vient en tête ensuite il y
a le sentiment anti-européen pourquoi
parce que l'Europe c'est la porte
ouverte aux immigrés et à l'immigration
et enfin il y a le positionnement sur
l'échelle gauche droite qu'il a aussi
joues voilà les trois variables clés qui
jouent encore plus que le reste et donc
il y a une assise idéologique et c'est
intéressant parce que les hommes et les
femmes c'est pareil je dis pas il y a
pas un profil différent des femmes et
des hommes qui votent et fans quand il
s'agit des idées c'est exactement la
même chose simplement Marine Le Pen a
permis à des femmes qui jusque là
hésitaient un peu à cause de la
personnalité de Jean-Marie Le Pen a
franchir le pas mais les idées sont les
mêmes d'abord les migrations l'Europe et
l'autorité j'oubliais une société
d'ordre bien sûr Jean-Yves Camus même je
reprends la question de Mathieu est-ce
que le vote protestataire se dilue dans
la normalisation on pourrait le dire le
dire comme ça ça fait des décennies que
j'essaye de
démolir l'idée de ce vote qui ne serait
que compter cet air quand Marine Le Pen
dit avant nous étions une force de
contestation aujourd'hui c'est fini
qu'est-ce qu'elle dit en creux elle dit
à l'époque de Jean-Marie Le Pen c'était
effectivement une force de contestation
elle essaye de marquer une transition
une mutation dans le leadership mais en
fait même à l'époque de Jean-Marie Le
Pen il y avait certainement une part de
contestation pure qui était plus forte
qu'aujourd'hui mais il y avait un
logiciel idéologique il n'y a pas des
millions de Français qui ont voté
pendant 30 ans pour un parti politique
par millions sans qu'il y ait derrière
un certain nombre d'idées des forces qui
les séduisaient le mouvement pouvait du
je le rappelle il démarre en 1953 en
1958 le général de Gaulle revient au
pouvoir c'est terminé on en parle plus
Jean-Marie Le Pen d'ailleurs devient
député non inscrite de Paris ah là le
rassemblement national né en 1972 et il
change de nom en 2018 il tourne
l'objectif de Jordan Bardella pour ces
élections européennes juste après on va
parler des sénatoriales c'est quoi c'est
d'abord de rogner l'électorat LR c'est
de continuer dans cette dans cette ligne
là dans cette stratégie là je pense
qu'il y a une chose alors d'abord il est
populaire Jordan Bardella c'est la
deuxième
personnalité politique aujourd'hui la
troisième pardon derrière Edouard
Philippe puis Marine Le Pen avec 29%
d'opinion positives dans le dans le
paysage ça en fait quand même sur les
trois personnalités politiques les plus
populaires deux qui viennent du
rassemblement national ensuite je pense
qu'effectivement il y a quelque chose
d'intéressant intellectuellement dans la
proposition qui est celle de de Jordan
Bardella qui est de faire cette sorte de
d'ouverture
ou plutôt de tentatives de retour aussi
à un électorat peut-être un petit peu
plus espp plus ou un petit peu plus
libéral que celui auquel Marine Le Pen
s'est arrêtée depuis maintenant le début
des années 2010 et même et même avant
donc il y a voilà quelque chose sûrement
une dimension plus identitaire
d'ailleurs on parlait de des appels du
pied de Jordan Bardella à Marion
maréchal Éric Zemmour a fait les mêmes
envers Jordan Bardella en l'appelant à
la cohérence et elle rejoindre malgré
tout et à quitter le rassemblement
national donc il y a cette dimension là
je pense qui qui cette faiblesse
d'empreinte sociale ce retour à
l'identitaire qui dit quelque chose du
positionnement idéologique de Marine Le
Pen et de l'inclinaison qu'elle va
vouloir donner au rassemblement national
pour les prochaines années parce que
elle sait aussi que c'est une chose qui
peut lui manquer à l'horizon 2027 et
est-ce que l'entente est aussi parfaite
que que l'impression qu'il nous donne
Jordan mardella et Marine Le Pen un
petit peu finir avec cette popularité
dont nous parlez par voilà ou ce verre
de Londres à la chaîne tendre c'est
quelque chose qui est vrai à l'instant T
ensuite ça évolue en fonction et dire de
l'humeur des uns et des autres et puis
aussi des résultats électro il y a une
complémentarité il y a une
complémentarité qui est dictée parce que
vous venez d'indiquer sur les positions
de jardin Bardella qui est aussi une
complémentarité du genre d'ailleurs il
est aussi une complémentarité de
génération ensuite ce qu'elle deviendra
son grandes parties les résultats qu'ils
diront alors on va vous parler d'Éric
Zemmour on va écouter un extrait du
discours d'Éric Zemmour ce dimanche il
faisait lui aussi sa rentrée politique
il a fait de l'éducation son cheval de
bataille avec son réseau de parents
d'élèves les parents vigilants écoutez
on sait cette rentrée scolaire je veux
vous le dire mes chers amis je crois que
l'opiniâtreté de nos parents vigilants
n'est pas étrangère au départ du
l'ancien ministre de l'éducation
nationale monsieur papendaye
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
n'ayez pas peur de savourer cette
victoire vous la méritez
nos parents vigilants ont été en
première ligne toute l'année pour
défendre nos enfants pour dénoncer le
grand endocrinement pour exiger le
retour de l'excellente du mérite de
l'effort et de la discipline je les dis
cette semaine je veux que nos enfants
apprennent la BCD avant le LGBT
[Applaudissements]
rentrée je vous le demande
présentez-vous à toutes les élections de
parents d'élèves nous avons le pouvoir
de peser davantage encore c'est possible
c'est utile et c'est notre devoir
votre avis sur ce discours cet appel aux
parents d'élèves cette stratégie de
d'entrisme par les par les conseils de
de classe alors je vais ce que je dis
est peut-être un peu daté mais on va en
général plus de maman que de papa dans
les conseils de classe donc ça cadre pas
avec ce que vous décriviez de
l'électorat Zemmour avec la conception
en tout cas que lui-même a déjà parce
que il a eu des propos mais ceci dit
c'est pas une stratégie qui l'a inventé
le Front national il y a très longtemps
dès le dès l'origine avait essayé de
noyauter de créer des associations de
parents d'élèves d'être présents dans
les écoles donc c'est pas c'est pas une
nouveauté simplement c'est tout à fait
dans sa ligne
identitaire et donc c'est tout à fait
logique mais c'est simplement là où il
est en guerre contre le wokisme contre
Papen Diagne contre les LGBT il est sur
une ligne
beaucoup plus dur que Marine Le Pen
derrière il a une forme de conservatisme
moral qu'elle n'a pas et ça c'est
quelque chose aussi qui rebute une
partie de l'électorat de Marine Le Pen
Marine Le Pen se présente comme une
quasi féministe de quoi donner de
l'urticaire à Éric Zemmour quand elle a
écrit son bouquin contre Flo elle dit
qu'elle comprend les femmes qui avortent
elle dit que c'est slogans de campagne
c'est femme d'État donc elle joue sur le
côté féminin et elle se présente
effectivement comme moderne on peut pas
qualifier véritablement de moderne et
avec Zemmour c'est plutôt la défense de
la tradition donc mais sinon sur le plan
de la défense de l'école
ils sont d'accord tous les deux
simplement il va encore plus loin et le
grand endoctrinement c'est la suite
logique du Grand remplacement Jean-Yves
Camus
dans le discours de d'Éric Zemmour ce
dimanche mais plus généralement dans
dans ses discours alors ce qui me frappe
d'abord et c'est peut-être un petit peu
à contre-courant c'est qu'Eric Zemmour
conserve a priori un socle électoral qui
n'est pas complètement négligeable parce
que quand on parle de rien faire 7 % à
la présidentielle d'abord ça vous assure
financièrement la possibilité de tenir
jusqu'à la prochaine échéance d'où
l'importance de celle des européennes et
ensuite c'est quand même pas
complètement négligeable oui je parlais
d'échecs dans mes titres mais quand on
regarde le score d'Éric Zemmour vu du du
de voilà des socialistes ou de ou des
républicains tout est relatif il s'est
passé avec Éric Zemmour la même chose
qu'avec la candidature de Jean-Pierre
Chevènement en 2002 c'est à dire qu'au
mois de janvier les sondages étaient
tels que l'un et l'autre se voyaient
devant et en position d'accéder au
second tour ça c'est les sondages de
janvier mais il faut regarder les
sondages de mars et c'est là que la
grande déconvenue est arrivé parce que
assez naturellement moi j'ai toujours
pensé
Éric Zemmour devant Marine Le Pen c'est
quand même extrêmement improbable alors
ça a créé un sentiment de déception d'un
sentiment d'injustice extrêmement fort
chez les militants de reconquête mais
même s'ils étaient d'après ce que j'ai
pu lire deux fois moins nombreux à
Gréoux que l'année dernière ça reste
quand même un événement qui est pas
complètement négligeable il va
simplement avoir un problème de
renouvellement parce que
sociologiquement ces électorat est assez
marqué
sociologiquement cette électorat
se renouveler et puis les thèmes si vous
voulez
se répète quand même n'est variété
d'événements en événements on peut
évidemment être d'accord avec eux mais
je vois pas comment on peser plus que 7%
ce qui suffit pour être représenté au
Parlement européen on ignorant
totalement la question sociale ce qui
est quand même la marque de fabrique du
discours de Gréoux on peut effectivement
dire je suis le seul à être
véritablement antiwok enfin encore que
quand on regarde chez LR et au
rassemblement national il y en a des
anti-works mais on ne peut pas à un
moment donné à moins s'adresser à un
public qui n'a vraiment aucun problème
dans la vie
ignorer totalement les questions
sociales qui comme vous l'avez dit tout
à l'heure ont occupé la rue la rue
pendant les deux années qui viennent de
s'écouler ça c'est un point faible le le
rôle comment vous l'avez étudié Adrien
broche de d'Éric Zemmour dans la on est
sur cette stratégie de la discrétion de
Marine Le Pen sur cette normalisation
payante
bon c'est un peu une évidence mais on a
commencé à le dire Éric Zemmour étant
plus radical dans ses propos très
sombres aussi des discours
il y a pas il y a jamais beaucoup
d'espoir dans les discours d'Éric
Zemmour ça c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire donc ça participe aussi de la
normalisation de Marine Le Pen c'est une
évidence où il faut quand même le
détailler du recentrage en tout cas de
la banalisation il a servi je pense
pendant la campagne présidentielle de
paratonnerre et il continue un petit peu
de le faire c'est intéressant quand on
discute quand on écoute en fait le
discours de rentrée d'Eric Zemmour comme
chacun de ces discours de toute manière
ou celui de Marion maréchal la tonalité
post-élection européenne elle ne
concerne que l'immigration la submersion
migratoires l'islamisation du pays
l'antiwokies cette cette bataille qui
fait d'ailleurs un petit peu penser à
l'altright et aux tonalités qu'il y a à
l'extrême droite américaine sur ce sur
cette lutte anti wok elle est assez peu
donnée effectivement sur la question
sociale bien sûr il y a toujours un peu
de référence à l'état obèse etc mais
assez peu là dessus et il s'agit assez
peu au final d'Europe ou d'Union
Européenne mais d'abord parce que
évidemment l'accent n'est pas mis sur
comme ça peut être le cas au
rassemblement national parce que je
pense qu'il y a malgré tout et c'est
aussi sa sociologie électorale là celle
d'ailleurs que cherchent un petit peu à
obtenir aussi Marine Le Pen un électorat
beaucoup moins hostile à l'Union
européenne qui aurait soit peur d'y
perdre économiquement ou alors qui a le
sentiment malgré les imperfections de la
bureaucratie
européenne ou comment est-ce qu'il
l'appellerait peu importe qu'il y a une
culture une civilisation européenne que
dans le sillage du Grèce des années 70
que partage cette électorale là et cette
frange là de la population française le
RN est reconquête se prépare pour les
élections européennes avant ça il y a
les sénatoriales 24 septembre on en
parle tout de suite avec Alexandre
pusard qui va nous rejoindre sur ce
plateau c'est la chronique de ce sens
public bonsoir Alex on va voir avec vous
les enjeux de ces élections sénatoriales
d'abord pour le rassemblement national
et bien Thomas d'abord il faut préciser
que actuellement le rassemblement
national n'a pas de sénateur mais ce
parti compte bien
remédier puisque le dimanche 24
septembre prochaines élections sénateur
sénatorial et bien le RN va présenter
des cas en des candidats quasiment dans
tous les départements qui sont concernés
par ce scrutin sauf le lot la Lozère
Paris et la plupart des départements
d'outre-mer et au sein du RN il y a
précisément trois départements qui sont
ciblés pour remporter des sièges de
sénateurs il s'agit du Nord du
Pas-de-Calais et de la Moselle
l'objectif du rassemblement national
c'est de conquérir entre 5 et 10 sièges
de sénateurs et on le rappelle pour
avoir un gros politique au Sénat et donc
du temps de parole il faut au moins 10
sièges de sénateurs donc ça s'annonce
compliqué pour la formation de Marine Le
Pen alors on profite de ces deux
semaines qui nous restent avant les
sénatoriales pour faire régulièrement
dans cette émission et dans les
émissions de la chaîne qui mieux que
nous de la pédagogie on va expliquer
pourquoi il y a si peu de
représentations durant un ensemblement
national au Sénat et bien cela
s'explique Thomas par le mode de scrutin
de ces élections sénatoriales puisque le
sénateurs sont élus au suffrage univers
indirect par un collège de grands
électeurs qui est composé à 95% de
conseillers municipaux et donc le
résultat de ces élections sénatoriales
dépend fortement de celui des dernières
élections municipales en 2020 et à
l'époque le RN avait fait un faible
score aux municipal en enregistrant que
840 conseils municipaux sur 258 communes
dans tout le pays et c'était un score
plus faible quand 2014 donc le RN est
peu représenté au Sénat tout simplement
car il y a et bien pour le RN et une
faible implantation locale dans nos
communes alors voilà pour le RN du côté
de reconquête ESCA une stratégie pour
les sénatoriales très bien non il y en a
pas le parti d'Éric Zemmour compte tout
simplement enjamber cette élection il
n'y a pas de candidat presque pas de
candidat reconquête aux élections
sénatoriales j'ai seulement trouvé une
liste avec l'étiquette reconquête dans
le département du Nord mais on notera
qu'actuellement reconquête a déjà un
sénateur il s'agit de Stéphane Ravier
qu'on voit ici à la rentrée du parti
reconquête avec Éric Zemmour Stéphane le
sénateur des Bouches-du-Rhône qui a été
élu depuis 2014 sur l'étiquette du RN et
il a rallié Éric Zemmour à la
présidentielle 2022 en tout cas Stéphane
Ravier lui il n'est pas concerné par ses
élections sénatoriales le dimanche 24
septembre puisque seul la moitié des
sièges du Sénat et renouveler dans ce
scrutin merci beaucoup Alexandre
Poussard à tout à l'heure dans notre
salon secondaire
Marine Le Pen à la présidentielle a
plutôt fait si je ne me trompe des bons
scores dans les petites villes ou dans
les villes moyennes pourquoi ça ne se
transforme pas lors des municipales ou
lors des scrutins on va dire
territoriaux comment vous expliquer ce
paradoxe apparent d'abord ça prend du
temps mais c'est vrai que c'est au début
quand il a commencé à percer le front
national il perçait dans les grandes
villes et dans les grandes villes et à
partir de 2002 il commence à percer dans
les villes moyennes puis les petites
villes puis les communes rurales donc
c'est véritablement là ces zones de
force avec l'idée c'est un petit peu les
petites patries à la morale ça va
défendre les souveraineté locale contre
l'intercommunal etc mais de là c'est des
élections de notables il faut être connu
il y a beaucoup de communes en France
vous avez 36 000 communes donc il faut
énormément de temps vous avez un
appareil qui n'est pas en parfaite état
de marche encore après les différentes
crises donc c'est très difficile de
s'implanter localement mais ils vont y
arriver mais c'est un parti qui est un
nain au niveau de l'implantation locale
tant municipal que régional alors ça n'a
pas empêché Marine Le Pen de se
qualifier deux fois pour la finale de la
présidentielle mais est-ce que c'est pas
quand même un handicap qui peut rester
rédhibitoire cette absence d'ancrage
territorial alors c'est une situation
assez paradoxale parce que finalement
c'est une situation qui était à l'image
de ce qu'elle calendrier électoral celui
de l'institutions de la Cinquième
République on mise uniquement sur
l'élection Rennes l'élection
présidentielle et puis on se dit que
ensuite le reste suivra sauf que pour
l'instant le reste ne suit pas au niveau
local
ça n'empêche que d'abord le scrutin de
2020 n'était plus être pas le meilleur
le plus facile on était quand même dans
une dans une conjoncture assez
particulière dans ces élections
municipales donc le RN peut
effectivement mieux faire à la suivante
mais effectivement il y a un appareil
qui est assez inégal une implantation
qui était assez inégale selon les selon
les départements et puis tout simplement
une liste aux élections municipales dans
un certain nombre de communes ça demande
du monde c'est pas un candidat que vous
présentez il faut que vous que vous
trouviez 31 45 individus presque
présenté ce qui est très intéressant
d'ailleurs c'est qu'il fut une époque où
on entendait beaucoup dire au Front
national vous savez c'est difficile de
de boucler le lit parce que il y a une
forme de propre sociale qui se porte sur
les gens qui sont candidats du parti et
au fond certains ne veulent pas y aller
c'est de moins en moins vrai aujourd'hui
effectivement donc ça pourrait permettre
à l'avenir orn de combler un petit peu
ce déficit les très grandes villes je
pense en particulier à Paris on vient
dire il y a pas d'hélice rassemblement
national à Paris bon bah s'il y a pas de
livre c'est parce qu'il y a pas de
perspective il y en a ni aux real ni au
législatives ni à la présidence par
contre il y a un énorme terrain qui est
les les petites villes et leur et ce que
j'appelle le four rural c'est-à-dire le
les endroits où effectivement on est
dans la ruralité mais où les gens ne
sont plus agriculteurs ils font tous les
jours leur trajet rappelez-vous le début
de la crise des gilets jaunes et la
question des carburants ils font tous
les jours leur trajet aller-retour pour
accompagner leurs gamins à l'école et
pour aller travailler dans une ville
dans une ville moyenne là il y a un
énorme vivier tes lecteur et c'est pas
uniquement la question des petites
patries qui effectivement existent mais
qui résonnent plus je trouve moins avec
ce qui est reconquête et ce quelle
partie d'Eric Zemmour c'est tout
simplement parce qu'il y a du réel
problème de déplacement de réels
problèmes de services publics qui
disparaissent sous s'éloignent et de
réel problème de pouvoir d'achat qui
touche ces gens qui souvent n'ont pas
les mêmes salaires que les habitants des
grandes villes Mathieu c'est récent
surtout l'implantation du rassemblement
national d'alimentation réussie il y a
une première vague en souvient Vitrolles
Toulon orange Marignane et puis qui qui
avait en fait fini un peu en notre
boudin c'est l'expression mais c'est
2014 qui montre que le rassemblement
national s'implante Fréjus
Hénin-Beaumont après Bocquet enfin des
choses des choses des petits territoires
ça n'est pas encore grand chose mais et
Perpignan regardez Béziers même s'il est
pas forcément rassemblement national
mais globalement il y a maintenant des
Edils étiquetés rassemblement national
qui se sont notés et qui ont voient au
chapitre comme des petits barons locaux
et donc tout ça prend du temps c'est pas
encore un parti de notable locaux comme
le fut autrefois le socialiste ou de
grands partis de droite mais on voit
bien que que cette position avance quand
même et surtout à partir de 2014 les
élus Rassemblement National Front
national à l'époque et vite passer moi
encore l'expression deux fois il leur
pression municipale exactement contre ce
1995 et ce 2014 on a quand même un gain
de crédibilité je rappelle que Marignane
ça se passe pas super bien ce je peux
encore celui qui a réussi le mieux
Vitrolles ça se passe pas bien du tout
et tout long ça tourne au fiasco général
donc devant son 2 ont tiré leur épingle
du jeu le maire de Marignane de l'époque
mais il a quitté la scène politique et
l'inoxydable maire d'Orange qui restait
très très longtemps qui est allé en
Suisse sous notre cieux un dernier mot
sur les élections européennes donc là on
se projette au mois de juin peut-être
faire un peu d'histoire Adrien broche
c'est ce sont des élections
traditionnellement favorables au
rassemblement national ou si j'élargi
aux parties de droites radicales
oui alors on peut dire ça aussi pour des
raisons différentes des vers dans
l'histoire politique française
contemporaine ce qu'on peut anticiper
c'est qu'effectivement Marine Le Pen et
Jordan Bardella jouent plutôt la la
carte d'un référendum pour ou contre
Macron quoi c'est à dire une
élections
de mi-manda là où Eric Zemmour pourrait
jouer si on reste sur les questions
extraordinaire plutôt une une carte
référendaire pour ou contre
l'immigration ce qui a commencé à non on
peut estimer que la première est plus
maligne tactiquement peut-être que la
que la deuxième mais il est certain
qu'en tout cas si elle joue ce créneau
là avoir évidemment les prochaines
semaines les prochains mois le débat
immigration aussi qui va se tenir à
l'Assemblée nationale comment tout ça va
se s'articuler mais ça pourrait être
encore une fois une carte une carte
gagnante pour Marine Le Pen sans faire
de s'en faire de politique fiction merci
beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir participé
à ce premier débat de ce sens public je
vous dis à bientôt sur sur public c'est